you
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is Alex
Bain I'm the head of marketing analytics
at nest I'm here with Jesse Nichols the
head of growth at nest and today we'll
be talking about how nest 2 uses Google
cloud and tableau to drive its business
you can ask questions any time on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them let's get started great
so first of all since alex is a marketer
and I run growth primarily from the
standpoint of growth analytics and
experimentation this presentation will
be through how we drive the business
through that lens we use Google
Analytics to drive a huge portion of our
marketing analysis and since we use
analytics 360 we also leverage the
integration that sends all of your
website analytics data into Google
bigquery of course within the cloud so
to begin we'll talk first about why you
would use tableau versus just using the
Google Analytics interface to do
marketing analytics well how you could
get extra insights from that then we'll
talk more about why you would connect to
bigquery versus the Google Analytics API
which tableau also has a negative native
integration with and finally we will end
with some tips and tricks to get you off
to the races
perfect so let's talk about tableau
versus the GA interface so both tools
are capable of segmenting users and
visualizing data so how do you decide
when you want to use one versus the
other so for Google Analytics channel
reporting is very quick and easy if you
just want to understand sessions from a
specific channel like display you can
get that very fast in GA additionally
AdWords so shopping ads YouTube
double-click search console data a
handful of these dimensions and metrics
simply aren't available through the API
and GA is a great resource in those
cases and then finally simple answers to
simple questions so sometimes you just
need to grab one metric a one metric
answer to a question and no reason to go
beyond GA in those cases so channel
reporting for example like sometimes you
get
request about a specific flighted
campaign and and how it performed it's
just easier to get that in GA if it's
you know a click away and you can you
can bookmark that send it out to
stakeholders as well so then when do you
use tableau so if you have multiple data
sources for example you can flow in the
product hierarchy so if you want to
group a number of SKUs a certain way
very easy to create that that reference
table and and change it dynamically you
know as needed as new products come out
and have tableau sort of pointed there
and in grouping data that way so pre
click marketing data anything you're
doing offline for example you can create
that as you know another data source
that you would fold in alongside all of
the GA data that you have flowing in
custom dashboards so dashboards are
great for tracking campaign or channel
performance and marketers love pretty
dashboards which tableau makes it very
easy to build so if you want to create
multiple views of multiple metrics all
in one place
very easy to do that in tableau and then
finally performance versus goals so if
you establish goals at the beginning of
the year and you have those documented
somewhere and that you see that in the
visual here where you have kind of gray
bars referencing the goals then you can
flow in the actuals through bigquery
into tableau each week that compares how
you did against your goals very very
helpful as a kind of ongoing reference
and say like a weekly stakeholder
meeting exactly and similarly when
you're doing site al analysis or growth
optimization analysis Google Analytics
is a fantastic tool for just digging
around and exploring the data I mean
first and foremost when someone is
asking a straightforward question a
single answer question it's just way
easier to go through the interface and
and find it in the can report so it's
like someone's asking how did this one
URL do from my you know a temporary
campaign we just launched or what's the
percent of mobile traffic or what's the
percent of EU traffic from this specific
country a lot of that analysis it's a
single answer
not gonna have to go get it again find
it in GA give it move on again even when
the data consumer is myself it's often a
lot easier to start an exploratory
analysis from within Google Analytics if
you know there was a recent issue where
I was trying to find if there were any
browser versions affected by a site
update tech technology update and it's
just easier to dig through the interface
find out what if anything was at risk
and give an answer that finally the the
reason that I would use Google Analytics
as opposed to tableau for analysis is
this kind of segmentation tool that GA
provides where it's basically a WYSIWYG
query builder and this agon so it's
gonna come back in full force we talked
about bigquery but this tool that you
see in the in the screenshot there
allows you to kind of functionally put
together the rudimentary basics of a
query and get a single answer or single
metric to a single question even if you
don't save that segment that's a pretty
handy tool but it's got its limits now
in tableau I totally agree fully custom
dashboards you just can't go wrong with
what you can do it's a blow I mean you
can go plenty wrong but usually you
you're you know the handcuffs are off to
a large degree and what you're trying to
design and build you know the the GA
dashboards are quite limited they're
quite constricting but you know with
tableau you've got design colors you're
really putting together a full dashboard
so I love that I can kind of have my
marketers give my market or something
that they can self serve with and
anticipate their needs and then there's
a handful of features again that you can
do inside the GA interface just a lot
easier when you're in tableau such as
providing filters to limit the amount of
data or change the data that someone's
seeing within a dashboard and even
controlling exactly which filters you
get which filters your which dimensions
you're filtering on so that kind of
stuff again way better through tableau
and then finally again these are
technologies that we leverage in great
detail when we start to flow in bigquery
data but even just your normal tableau
interface is far better at slicing your
data by a certain dimension or helping
you differentiate between line or bar
charts through coloring and other
classic data visit techniques so I think
that it's very situational but tableau
gives us a
a lot more flexibility when we're trying
to share out data okay so once you've
kind of had a sense of when you would
use tableau over GA it begs the question
of well why wouldn't you just be using
the Google Analytics API which is
already within tableau what is what's
the extra benefit you get through
bigquery sure so both are just a click
away as you can see in the visuals here
as you're setting up a new tableau file
very easy to pull in GA directly through
that API or bigquery directly through
that API but if you go the GA route and
you're working with a relatively long
large data set you can be waiting a long
time so bigquery comes back about as
fast as the cloud can get it to you so
for example if you're looking at
multi-year data sets and you're trying
to understand kind of seasonality trends
you're gonna get into sampled data on
the width if you're using the GA
interface and you won't know as you're
looking at noise if that is due to
seasonality or if that is due to
sampling so the bigquery interface or
API helps a bunch in that case yeah I
mean I don't know how many times I've
been asked about some very small metric
that is very important very
business-critical but it's like a needle
in a haystack and even with robust
sampling it's you just don't even don't
do it's almost not usable at a certain
level certainly as you go back in time
so I know you know I've been involved a
lot of analysis projects where precision
is just necessary and bigquery you just
have no reason to to give up precision
yep so you know I think as an analyst
certainly as someone who spends probably
80 90 percent of my time and analytics
tools having unlimited control over the
segmentation you're doing within the
data is incredibly powerful and it's
also incredibly frustrating when you
know the answers in the data and you
just can't get to it so you know the
limit here is that within tableaus GA
connection you are limited basically
it's a GA segment builder you have to
use the segmentation bill
I showed before NGA's interface before
you port it over to tableau and there
are a whole bunch of things that you
just can't build in that thing they just
feel just out of reach
specifically when you have let's say a
pretty standardized event naming
structure the same event could fire from
multiple pages you can't really tie
those two things together in the GA
segment builder but as an e-commerce
shop you know just knowing certain
product combinations being purchased
together again just and one of the
limits of the GA segment builder you
can't build these kind of multi products
combinations or moulton you know adding
multiple products to your cart over one
journey you can really only analyze one
product at a time so it's kind of a
showstopper for for a company like nest
but really pretty much any hit-level
logic you're constrained from doing in
the GA segment builder while in bigquery
you can see I shamefully use legacy
sequel to who to flag segments with
pretty much any segment logic that I
want and the you know the idea is that
that logic that you're putting in there
is all hit level and if you need to
reconcile segments that have sessions
that have multiple hits within one
session then you you just stack a bunch
of these and use and/or rules just to
key within the segment builder in some
sort of outer query and boom you have
any segment you could want to build you
could investigate any set of users that
you'd want it was really a freeing
moment as an analyst when I finally put
all these pieces together and was like
ok yeah came on it was a nice moment so
I strongly encourage digging into this
if you haven't used the GA data in
bigquery before you know the the thing
that you can stack on from there however
is I think an order of magnitude more
powerful so within again as an analyst
you're trying to find business insights
that are relative to their total scale
or relative to the context of the
greater business which is really about a
calculated metric a flat standard metric
it's kind of like is that a number
that's is that a big number is that a
large percent of our sales and so these
calculated metrics are critical they're
just absolutely vital to understanding
these ratios are vital to understanding
the health of the business or the health
of some metric you're pursuing and the
constraint with both GA s
segment builder and the tableau
connection of GA is that you can segment
some session metric and then you can
segment some other session metric but
because these are different segments the
numbers will have no relationship to
each other
you can't just divide one on top of
another to begin to create a new
calculated metric because again that
segment is applied to all data in the
structure and and you just kind of
hamstrung and you got to do a lot of
work to torture that out of the tool and
then recombine it it's just a real pain
but when you do this work within
bigquery you know like I showed you
before your segments you can kind of
capture however you want and you bring
you bubble them up as a standard kind of
pre calc metric and then you've got
yourself a numerator and denominator and
you can unlimited total control you know
if you were trying to seat yourself to
GA you'd have to have all this foresight
to set a goal and you only have a
certain number of goals even if you set
a goal it can only be applied in the
future not retroactive li this unlocks
all of that you're just kind of the
stress is gone maybe we should do the
example of shoppers nest comm that was a
good insight you had yeah that was
another kind of game-changing moment in
the way that we did analysis and looked
for growth opportunities
you know nest comm you can do all sorts
of things there you can manage your
control your devices you can get support
you can work with pro partners so only a
limited segment of our total shot visit
population are these shoppers and in
fact if you had a big support issue
you'd have a burst in traffic but that
and a decline in conversion rate when
really your shopper metric was totally
unaffected and so we really had to
figure out a way to not only pull those
shoppers out as a segment but then also
that needed to become the de facto
denominator in all of our calculations
and anything you stack on top of it kind
of had to take that as a given so we
defined a shopper and again started
building metrics on top of it how many
shoppers were you know what percent of
shoppers were going through this
specific flow what percent of shoppers
we're buying like a mixed transaction
with more than one piece of core
hardware in it and and again these calcs
had just been out of our reach before so
this was a real game-changer using
bigquery to match all this together and
then tableau to visualize
and then finally just ices cake a bit
you know I love to take the segmented
metrics that I've built in bigquery and
turn them into dimensions using a case
statement and I think you can probably
you know you could use this case
statement in either tableau every big
query but it is still the fundamental
work that you've the groundwork that
you've laid that enables this and what
this is referring to is you know usually
you're stuck with the dimensions that
you have to do you're kind of slices and
comparisons you country device category
channel things like that but really when
you want to know the impact of using a
thing versus not using a thing you if
you want to be able to compare that
fluidly in tableau you need to be able
to treat that as a dimension and so
using a case statement you take these
underlying rules that you've built and
you simply say okay well if they did
this thing there and you you name them
one thing if they didn't do it you name
them something else and boom you can do
you know this concept at least that mess
we refer to by slicing by or coloring by
to take all of the metrics you've built
below all the calculated metrics and
simply chop them by the the dimension
you just outlined so you know this is in
this example if we had a way to infer
that someone's what someone's dietary
preference was based on some series of
actions they could take we can build
those as metrics that would flag those
sessions and then you use case
statements to just kind of separate each
group into each other and then all of
the conversion rate metrics
argumentation traffic metrics everything
you kind of make beneath that can now be
sliced by this new magical infringement
dimension that you've pulled out above
so pretty great stuff and again huge
supercharge the analysis we've done
stakeholders feel very empowered when
they can play around with the interface
to make it reflect what they want to see
it also is the case then that if it all
lives in one viz 'that if you need to
make formatting changes or incorporate
new data sources later on you don't have
to do that times five if you've got that
built into the slice pie or color buy
it's all in one place yeah and again
this isn't really the same thing as just
using the grouping functionality on
emoji a data you actually need that due
to come through bigquery to be where
you're building metrics off of the
segment's in the first place and then
one
you've done that you can really
transform their utility with this
alright well hopefully we continue to
convince you at least a little bit that
using bigquery can use can give you far
more power when looking for marketing
and growth opportunities now we'll share
a few tips and tricks on how we use
traditional tableau capabilities layered
on top of this stuff what we've unlocked
with bigquery to again really power up
our marketing and business opportunities
so when you're evaluating marketing
performance it's very straightforward to
divide revenue and cost and call that
row as or return on adspend the
challenge is if you're selling something
that itself has cost a cost of goods
sold then by the time you've pulled that
out what you thought was breakeven is
actually quite unprofitable so what you
really want to do is look at margin or
profit divided by cost so if you have
the concept for a given say Hardware
product of what it costs to make that
product you can create a reference table
that has the price as well as the say
profit per unit and you can evaluate
what you're spending on marketing
relative to the profit that you're
bringing into the company and see if
your marketing is truly paying for
itself when it is it's very easy to
secure additional budget
yeah and it's a lot nicer to do it this
way than to ask your finance team if you
can put your margin into a custom metric
that flows over the open web so it's
even kind of upgrade even from I think
what normal GA capabilities we provide
so another example agencies can keep
their secret sauce so if your agency is
going out and negotiating preferential
costs with you know individual platforms
they may not want to share that or it
might be in the contract that it can't
be shared so they could create for
example an aggregated view of their cost
where it's it's aggregated at a level
that is you know it it's consistent with
their contract they could put that for
example into Google sheets which could
be pointed to tableau as an additional
data source so you can look at traffic
conversion etc and you can do it in the
context of the cost that the agency is
reporting to you
so you know makes it easy to be
compliant
additionally orders versus shipments so
it might be the case that what you're
seeing in GA is orders but if you are
actually shipping something if you had
pre orders if you had a backlog if
there's just some sort of delay with a
supplier there can be a gap between
orders and shipments and tableau helps
you to blend that data in and visualize
the difference can be very handy
especially at peak times of year
parameterizing dimensions sounds fancy
because it is so it's a classic tableau
feature it becomes even more powerful if
you have segments that you're working
with so you can create an if-then
statement that powers a parameter and
makes it easier for data consumers to
filter and control the dashboard so what
you see here is the slice by example we
were talking about before so what you
would do is you would you would create a
calculated field in tableau call it say
slice by that then points at the output
of a parameter so that allows you to
quickly toggle a dashboard between
looking at everything cut by country
versus looking at everything by device
can be really handy when you're talking
about conversion rates for example you
might see a very different conversion
rate on mobile versus tablet versus
desktop and the most common we have is
to look at you know to jump in and out
of say countries and regions yeah yeah I
mean this was also as we started to do
more of these kind of metrics as
dimensions concept where you're you're
taking your underlying KPIs
you know the core segments of traffic a
couple of your core metrics and you're
building all the visualizations you want
from that and then you use up this
parameter concept to start splitting by
you know all of the major metrics as
dimensions that you've built up again
you know finding opportunities is far
more fluid far more natural and then
also as you make changes to some of
these things if there's you know if
you're trying to analyze the improvement
to a conversion rate ever have to watch
a video or a number of videos or certain
videos or engaging with certain features
on your site it's a very painful process
of exploration in GA but once their
parameters in
tablo it's just a simple matter of
flipping through and looking for what
what strikes you that day it's also you
can build the view around whatever the
goals are for the business so that as
opposed to exposing kind of everything
that is possible to look at you narrow
the stakeholders field of view to only
the things that are the goals for the
year so if they're working on conversion
rate you know you'd be looking at that
just by country and device as opposed to
any other sort of possible dimension
that you could want to get crazy with
well and finally when using bigquery
with tableau again I assume this is a
bit of a choice you're making with most
of the times you're gonna have these two
tools to interact but you need to decide
whether you want a pre aggregated table
or something closer to like a visit or
session level table and really this is
the tension choice between do you want
speed or do you want flexibility or in
my case or you can place it with
laziness or do you really demand
complexity from the work that you're
about to do and and really you know for
pre Agra tea tables I think the the
single defining factor that's going to
make it the most obvious choice is
length of time and complexity of
underlying query if you've got a fairly
complex query and you're trying to do
analysis over 6 12 24 36 months you know
it's best if possible to simplify it
into a pre aggregated table and it'll be
just moving lightning-fast without any
pause so a lot of you historical
analysis you know if it's a relatively
simple function you just keep defending
it to the same table and it's kind of
rolling on its own
visit level tables I tend to think of
those more as an analyst tool than a
shareable dashboard they tend to move a
lot slower if you have a lot of data and
they're more way more flexible so you
don't need to think about every
aggregation you're going to do upfront
you know a classic example is something
where there are many possible
combinations of users that you would
want to explore and you don't want to
have to pre aggregate every possible one
beforehand so one of the cooler projects
that we've done based on this technology
having a visit level table in bigquery
powering through visualize do tableau
was a product level funnel starting from
the earliest point in the shopping flow
where you could engage
product which is different for each
product and then showing the fall-off as
you went through to conversion and you
know a single person could and often did
engage with multiple product funnels in
the single visit so you couldn't
possibly have had a doubter table that
really kind of summed all that up
without having just you know hundreds of
rows hundreds of lines of a sequel quote
and so with an inner query and a little
work in tableau we got we got to the
answers we need it and it was just
phenomenally insightful not something I
share with the general public of data
consumers at or at nest but it was super
helpful as far as growth analyst looking
for product level opportunities and to
wrap things up here is just my go-to
list of the dimensions as they appear in
bigquery they might seem a little random
or ad hoc to to you guys but out of the
200 plus dimensions that I use in
bigquery for GA data this represents 90%
of them and I get really really far out
of just this stuff so you know again I
can't encourage you enough to check out
that integration if you haven't already
it's a it's a order of magnitude
difference of the power that you get as
an analyst so stay tuned for live Q&A
we'll be back in less than a minute
you
welcome back so we've got some Q&A we'll
be going through now we've got some good
questions so first question how do you
account for discrepancies between what
you see in Google Analytics and what you
get from bigquery so great question does
come up from time to time I can think of
two sort of classic examples of where
you'd see this so one would be if you
are looking at a long time series for
example if you wanted to evaluate the
last three black Fridays that you'd had
some sort of campaign or promotion
around you're pulling in three years of
data with Google Analytics you'd get
into sampling so at a weak level you
would start to see discrepancies between
what were the actual data is at the
actual say visits in bigquery versus the
sampled view of that from GA so sampling
could be one reason why you would have a
discrepancy another kind of classic
reason might be that you have actually
structured the bigquery segments for
example that you're treating is kind of
the source of truth for say sessions it
may be the shopper example is a good one
to exclude support traffic or to exclude
traffic to forums so there's it's
intended to leave certain things out
whereas GA might be bringing in more raw
data so in that case the bigquery was
intended to be the source of truth and
it's it's it's often a purposeful way
yeah that was actually something I got a
lot of her the first reduced shopper
traffic as a metric is not very easily
or at all discoverable within Google
Analytics because you had to do some
segmentation magic much of which was
only available through what I was doing
in bigquery and so I had to kind of
retrain a lot of our data consumers as
to what the source of truth was for
certain types of questions and once it
kind of became the nominal Eicher people
accepted oh the shopper thing is a you
know a thing we get from tableau and
people you know went to the GA interface
less and less if that's not a question
that they felt like they knew the answer
there yes so let's see so the next
question would have been some of the
most insightful analysis projects using
tableau and bigquery
so a great question so I think GA by
default ends up doing a lot of last
click attribution when you're looking at
marketing so you'll you'll get a lot of
credit for search and less so for
display typically display advertising
what we started doing was to fold in a
aggregated data out of double-click we
had some rules set up around how to
attribute revenue back to display
advertising so we had that aggregated
and calculated and then we would kind of
compare that to channel level traffic
and activity that we were seeing in GA
you could map one against the other to
say okay how how's our marketing doing
holistically or at a channel level and
you know gave us the freedom to do to
invest more actively in display
advertising yeah and there's also one of
the other than the the funnel product
funnel one which was one of my earliest
proud sculptures was that I worked with
a couple other analysts you form up a
kind of a visitor table or visitor ID
table that would give us a sense of who
is a likely customer even if they
weren't logged in we did we don't
necessarily track any you know customer
identification level stuff in our GA
instance particularly but we do have a
lot of signals that they're a customer
namely that we know if they bought
something from in a store we can flag
that Google Analytics visitor ID as a
customer if they came from an email that
only went to customers we know that as
well and so we kind of built this rough
table that gave us an approximation of
who are known customers were and we
could start to segment by that data just
customer versus non customer traffic and
also incredibly insightful again when
you have no other way especially other
than maybe whether they're logged in or
not as to whether that person was
customer and and huge growth
opportunities were found to that yeah
let's see a next question can you get
real-time Google Analytics data through
bigquery much to Alex's disbelief you
actually can get it and I think it was
launched some time around last year you
know with real-time it was one of the
kind of last remaining messages and
benefits of going through the Google
Analytics interface but getting it into
bigquery data set and then using piping
it over to tableau has been really
phenomenal for our dev teams who do a
lot of uptime monitoring just kind of
like day-to-day check and they've
obviously got other lots of other uptime
tools but they'll blend those together
and look watch
you know QPS or rather more QP m
quarries for minutes site traffic per
minute and just general volume we also
use it around launch dates we were
pulling in lots of real-time data the
water as fresh as possible and being
about 15 minutes fresh gives us the
impact of individual press releases or
individual cycles that that we've put
out there and yeah real time to go
through bigquery has been just lightning
hot when it's when it's needed so let's
see next question what's the advantage
of using tableau over Google's data vis
product yeah I think they're talking
about Google Data studio which I've had
a lot of experience with as well both
they're phenomenal products both have a
connection to bigquery tableau has a few
advantages when you're doing some of the
more complex dashboard development or
this the analysis that we talk a lot
about the parameter parameterizing
dimensions and kind of slice by and some
instances of color by you just have more
control Google's data studio I love it
that you don't you have a single canvas
and you're kind of painting the element
of the dashboard on there so you don't
need the complexity of like one sheet
per graph like you need with tableau you
can just kind of work from one or two
canvas spaces and just mix and match as
you need so they're also just the same
as such tableau and GA kind of
situational but both have a bigquery
connection so I've used them both
terrific well that's all for today
please tune in next Tuesday for the next
cloud on-air thank you for watching
you